switch statements the switch statement
is a basic control structure used to
perform different actions based on
different conditions it's in most
programming languages and let me give
you an example you always start with the
word switch and then you're gonna put
what you're going to check against so
I'm gonna check against this new date
get de and this is gonna give you a
number for the day of the week and now
you're gonna check then you're gonna put
the word case and then you're gonna put
what the value is case is zero if new
date that get day is zero day equal
Sunday and break and when you break it
that means it's gonna go it's gonna be
done with the rest of the code here and
just go to the end of this the switch
statement case one if new date that get
day equals one then day is gonna equal
Monday break that means gonna go to the
end and so on now if you don't have the
word break there it will just go on to
the next case but when you do have the
word break it's gonna go all the way to
the end so let me add some more things
here first thing I'm saying let day to
treat the the day variable and then at
the end I'm gonna say console.log today
and if I run that you can see Friday I'm
making this video on a Friday let me
give you an example of a different case
which statement well this time we're
gonna create an animal giraffe now the
switch statement we're gonna pass in the
animal so we're passing in this variable
which happens to be giraffe and there's
me a few different cases now here you
can see that I have what case is right
one after the other case cow case
giraffe case dog case pig and something
to look at is that they don't say break
until down here so no matter which of
these animals ends up matching with it
just keeps going down until you get to
where it says console dot log and it's
going to console that log this this
animal will go on Noah's Ark
it's gonna break and when it breaks it
goes down to the bottom it's done with
the switch statement but then if it's
case spoon it's going to cancel that log
a spoilers on animal break I mean it's
gonna go to the end case dinosaur or
default consult that log this and will
not be on the ark now it default means
else
so if what's being tested does not match
any of the cases it's gonna go to
default so whether it's dinosaur or
whether it's anything else it's going to
conflict that log this will and will not
go on the ark so let's try that I'm
gonna run that and it's gonna say this
animal not going to art because of the
drift if we change this to spoon and we
run that a spoon is not an animal if we
change this to chicken and then we run
that this animal not be I'm Ark because
that the default and if we had put
dinosaur I would also go to the default
well that's the switch statement thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
check the description for links to more
information please subscribe and
remember use your code for good